how much alcohol we can safely consume
is being drastically rethought new
recommended guidelines for Canadians
advise even moderate drinking anything
more than two drinks a week puts your
health at risk the update is from the
Canadian Center on substance use and
addiction which reviewed six thousand
studies on alcohol use it defines a
standard drink as 12 ounces of beer 5
ounces of wine or one and a half ounces
of spirits according to the report
consuming no alcohol has significant
benefits to health and sleep three to
six drinks per week puts you at moderate
risk of developing seven types of cancer
including colon and breast cancer and
more than seven alcoholic drinks a week
puts you in increasingly high risk of
heart disease and stroke Mike droulet on
the new thinking about the risks of
drinking
whether it's at a bar a sporting event
or party alcohol isn't merely prevalent
it's celebrated in society today a
decade ago the medical community put a
number on what moderation looks like no
more than 15 drinks per week for men 10
for women but now after a review of 6
000 medical studies the new recommended
guideline is no more than two drinks we
were also very shocked about how
um how much different and how far we've
come in the science since 2011.
and um you know frankly we're like wow
like how you know how are we going to
get people to drink two drinks a week
how indeed the Canadian Center on
substance use and addiction wants
warning labels placed on bottles
informing consumers of the increased
risk for cancer heart disease and stroke
so after seven drinks the risk is
exponential
rate than it does at the moderate level
France has had labels on its bottles
since 1991. yet a recent study found
that they were too small and lacked
information in short they were
ineffective Canada's wine industry has
another idea labels but with more focus
on information than warnings uh 12 or 10
percent to alcohol bottle wine is going
to happen obviously a lesser amount of
alcohol than a 15 uh alcohol so uh
putting that on the label and
understanding what a standard breakiness
makes total sense to us now the
recommendations are just that
recommendations which helped Canada is
in the process of reviewing in the
meantime from a long-term medical point
of view the news isn't all Grim if
you've been drinking really heavily for
the last decade and we're very unaware
of these risks there is the potential
the damage isn't necessarily done it's a
dramatic shift from previous reports
well Canadians listen
Mike drolet Global News Toronto